what's going on everybody and welcome to
another Bitcoin paper explained video in
the last video we covered the abstract
of this paper which was actually kind of
dense compared to at least what this
section will be if you're looking for a
good overview of what bitcoin actually
is I highly suggest you watch that video
at least before this one as it covers
the basis of what you know bitcoin is
what it solves and why it works for your
brave souls who not only actually made
it through the first video but decided
to continue on the good news is that the
introduction section is really a breeze
compared to all the stuff we had to
cover in the abstract so that's exciting
so when I was with that let's go ahead
and continue on so starting at the
introductions section here let's begin
commerce on the internet has come to
rely almost exclusively on financial
institutions serving as trusted third
parties to process electronic payments
while the system works well enough for
most transactions it still suffers from
the inherent weaknesses of the trust
based model so here it's further
explained why there even is a problem in
the first place and why it needs fixing
more a little bit on that note to come
all internet financial transactions are
requiring a third party to mediate
really every single transaction so this
is both in disputes any actual mediation
of the processing of these transactions
which is actually very cumbersome to
validate on both both ends so while this
system you know it works and people
accept it it's actually flawed in many
ways so continuing on with the paper
with the possibility of reversal the
need for trust spreads so merchants must
be weary of their customers hassling
them for more information than they
would otherwise need a certain
percentage of fraud is accepted as
unavoidable these costs
and payment uncertainties can be avoided
in person by using physical currency but
no mechanism exists to make payments
over a communications channel without a
trusted party now I had kind of planned
this video before watching these New
York hearings so I'm not sure if anybody
is following at least right now if
you're watching my videos as they come
out what's going on right now is the is
New York is having hearings on you know
just Bitcoin in virtual currencies and
how ought they be regulated at least for
me I'm of the mindset I don't really
agree with them regulating these
currencies other than possibly the
exchanges and they already are regulated
a lot of the people that are on these
you know this these panels and stuff
that are speaking what I'm a little
unhappy with is that they all operate
businesses that work as a sort of
exchange from the dollar to Bitcoin so
you've got people from a coin base and
you have you know the guy from overstock
and you know other people that are you
know working in that kind of scenario
and situation and they're not really
talking to people that aren't managing a
business that is in some sort of
transaction between Bitcoin and dollar
but the problem here is exactly this
right the people working for coin base
of course they would like the reason and
more regulation because that would
benefit them but in the case of coin
base for example if you want to get
anything from coinbase you have to give
them a lot of information and a lot of
the exchanges that you want to be honest
mount GOx especially you have to give
them a lot of personal information and
so I think that goes almost it's like
the antithesis to why Satoshi Nakamoto
actually wanted here basically word for
word I mean we can basically just see
that right now that merchants must be
weary of their customers hassling them
for more information than they would
otherwise need so anyway I see these
this hearing in New York and I and I see
this as a direct
opposite of what is actually intended by
satoshi nakamoto here so anyway I just
wanted to point that out but we'll
continue on for now so here you know
back to the paper and what I originally
intended to say here we begin attacking
some of the major flaws in the current
system that exists today so it's wise to
go ahead and note that despite what I
just said
this original Bitcoin paper does not
actually attack any entity's dollar
central bank's anything like that right
the paper actually takes no political
stance at all it's merely a scientific
and efficiency proposition but part of
the efficiency and safety and all of
that is in the fact that merchants do
not need to get all this personal
information on people but with
regulation that's exactly what we'll end
up having you know occurring because
people are afraid that you know
criminals are gonna use it to launder
money or or continue to do their illicit
activities with Bitcoin but I still I
think it's extremely important to note
that that is not the intention of
Bitcoin and I think I'm not even sure
how you could possibly you know force
regulation on it to be honest but anyway
moving on so with the reversibility
right of the let's say the US dollar the
need for an entity that can be trusted
becomes greater so the need for someone
to actually middleman various things
becomes greater anyone selling goods has
to vet their customers this is
incredibly apparent like I was saying if
you actually try to buy Bitcoin right
usually you have to wait three to five
days by a bank transfer most places
won't even take paypal the ones that do
come into play in the next sentence
concerning the you know it's certain
there's a certain percentage of fraud is
kind of thought to be accepted and
unavoidable right so you can actually
buy with PayPal on places like let's say
but local bitcoins only you have to pay
a massive increase over market usually
as much as fifty percent so that gauges
vaguely for you how much fraud and risk
there is if people are given the
opportunity to reverse their payment for
a non-reversible anonymous
set so doesn't that make you feel warm
and fuzzy inside if any of you have ever
you know dealt with PayPal disputes you
know the drill you get a charge back you
got screwed that's pretty much it right
it's so very rarely are you ever able to
win a chargeback dispute unless you have
a lot of information and all of this
information collection is really
unnecessary if you use something like
Bitcoin also if you consider places like
local Bitcoin where people do take
paypal it's unnecessary that people pay
a 50% markup in order to fund the
scoundrels that steal and pilfer from
the system right this is a kinda this is
a massive flaw in efficiency I shouldn't
have had pay my first Bitcoin came from
local bitcoins I paid a massive markup
because it was my first purchase there
and it was via PayPal I shouldn't have
had to pay that massive markup I'm legit
right but what the seller doesn't know
that and the sellers not protected so
unless there's a middle man a true
middleman of sorts you know that can
help them but PayPal won't help them
last I heard PayPal was locking user
accounts that we're dealing with virtual
currencies quote-unquote which is at the
risk of a future I digress this is
pretty hypocritical so I've been using
PayPal for years for virtual currency
transactions I actually ran a business
doing this and I've actually had to tell
them that I was that's what I was doing
when my account got locked for money
laundering suspicions and after I told
them that I was in the virtual currency
exchanges my account got unlocked so a
little bit of hypocrisy and I still see
major monetary exchanges like player
auctions calm for example they are still
operating on PayPal so I'm not sure
what's going on there anyway
back into this intro so with local
bitcoins for example when buying there
you've got to supply usually a photo ID
some secret codes emails name maybe some
more personal information just to get
someone to work with you alright same
with getting verified on mount GOx name
bank account info credit card bank
statement bills with your address that
matches your ID
blah blah blah all of this information
is waste not necessary it's risky and
but it's needed to protect the business
from as much fraud as possible but to
you and me the legit people this is
violating and somewhat costly your
information is actually valuable and so
is your privacy and so again that just
brings me back to this whole regulation
stuff this is going against every you
know as soon as you regulate it you're
giving it the same pitfalls as as you
know kind of some of the main reasons
satoshi nakamoto even created Bitcoin so
that would be a huge shame to see that
happen anyway
as such we see what happens when there
is no trusted third party to mediate
anything you know hell breaks loose
people scam their hearts out mark-up
information costs everything goes up so
we see what happens when there is no
third party but that's the idea of you
know the Bitcoin network is we can do
that and there is no need to regulate
the Bitcoin network it is
self-regulating there is no need for
this
anyway it's moving on back to the actual
coding of the paper what is needed is an
electronic payment system based on
cryptographic proof instead of trust
allowing to willing parties to transact
directly with each other without the
need for a trusted third party
transactions that are computationally
impractical to reverse would protect
sellers from fraud and routine escrow
mechanisms would could be easily
implemented to protect buyers in this
paper we propose a solution to the
double spending problem using a
peer-to-peer distributed timestamp
server to generate computational proof
of the chronological order of
transactions the system is secure as
long as honest nodes collective
collectively control more CPU power than
any cooperating group of attacker nodes
so here's where the answer is proposed a
mathematical scientific solution to the
issue of trust and security rather than
some third party or entity proposed is
the topic we covered in the abstract
already this peer-to-peer time-stamped
server to generate computational proof
all of the transactions that have
occurred
this system would be you know perfectly
secure so long as honest people
collectively outweigh dishonest people
in CPU power so that's your introduction
paragraph really not too much new though
the actual problem of why the current
system is so greatly inefficient is
covered and explained here just kind of
more broken down than it was in the
abstract and that's what we'll be seeing
throughout the rest of the paper really
is just each kind of topic broken down
further in the next video we're gonna be
covering the transactions section which
will be slightly more dense than this
section but again I do think it should
be pointed out here that in the abstract
this section in this entire paper
Satoshi Nakamoto the person or the group
never actually assumed any sort of
political positioning so the purpose and
goal for Bitcoin was just for a fishin C
and is just to be doing it right so this
isn't we're you know really important to
remember as we move forward since at the
moment we have very strongly opinion
people also with their own agenda myself
included who feel that bitcoin is
something more than just you know a
great scientific achievement there's
more to it and there is you know
philosophical and political gains to be
had and I do worry about you know things
like this New York hearing where you
know the people that are running these
businesses that would profit
significantly from Bitcoin regulation
are forgetting what the you know the
whole point of Bitcoin was so that we
didn't have to worry about chargebacks
and reversals which we probably never
will but then regulation with the whole
you know giving up of all this third
party in our your information to a third
party which would be any business that
is willing to accept Bitcoin I think is
just absurd I mean that was the point of
this stuff and in the day I don't know
why anybody needs to be given the green
light to transact in Bitcoin the only
people that do or people that transact
in Bitcoin and US dollars so the only
people that really need to be regulated
in any way would be the exchanges and
they would be regulated in the sense
that they need to you know be watching
out for money laundering
criminals just as any you know any
exchange would so anyways that's my
opinion if you've cut your opinion go
ahead and post it below since I was
given mine
so anyways stay tuned for the next video
as always thanks for watching thanks for
all the support in the subscriptions and
until next time